Okay, I mentioned earlier that
getting everything up-to-date would
require merging the local and
remote branches.
How does this work in practice?
As it turns out,
when you have a remote set-up,
Git stores local copies of
all the remote branches.
These will each contain the state of the
remote branch as of the last time you
pushed or pulled the branch.
Let's look at how this would play out
over the lifetime of a repository.
We'll consider a repository that got
created on GitHub with a readme, and
then got cloned.
Remember that cloning sets up
a remote for you called origin.
We've already seen that when you clone
a repository, you get a local branch
called master, that points to
the same commit as the remote one.
But what you haven't seen yet
is that you also get a local copy of
the last known position of
that branch on the remote.
The name of that branch includes
the name of the remote, origin,
since you can have
multiple remotes set up,
as well as the name of
the branch on the remote.
In this case, master,
which is to be separated by a slash.
So in this case, it'll be origin/master.
And since we've just had
an interaction with the remote,
it's currently in the same location
as the actual remote version.
Let's consider what happens when you
make commit on the master
branch locally.
As usual,
when you make a commit on a branch,
that branch will get updated
to point to the new commit.
But, neither the local
origin/master branch, nor
the actual master branch
on the GitHub repository,
will get updated because you haven't
communicated that you want to do that.
However, if you push the master branch,
the local origin/master branch and
the remote GitHub branch will
get updated with the new commit.
Similarly, if this branch were
to get updated on GitHub and
then we pulled, both of these would
get updated with the new commit.
Let's go back to thinking about what
happens if you've got different
changes on each repository, with one
change locally and another remote.
It turns out that you can update just
the local copy of the remote branch,
leaving your actual local version alone
by running the command git fetch.
In cases like this, where there
are potentially conflicting changes,
using git fetch to update the local
copy of the remote branch can be nice,
so that you can use git log and git diff
to see what changes were introduced,
both on the local and
remote repositories.
This way,
if you're going to be offline for
a while,
say if you're about to get on a plane,
you can update your local copy of
the remote branch before you leave.
And then you'll have access to any
updates that have been made to
the remote since you last synced up,
while you were offline.
But you don't have to act on
combining those commits right away.
Speaking of combining changes,
now that you have the commit from GitHub
on your local repository, it's now
possible to incorporate them into
your master branch, using git merge.
It turns out that this is exactly
what happens when you do a git pull.
First, the remote branch gets fetched,
updating the local copy
of the remote branch.
Then, that branch gets
merged into the local one.
To put it more concretely, in this case,
fetching updates origin/master with the
contents of GitHub's master branch, and
then origin/master is
merged into master.
So git pull is the same as git
fetch followed by git merge.
Now Caroline will demonstrate doing this
process on the recipes repository on
the command line.
>> I can update the local copies by
running git fetch origin, which will
update all of the local copies of
every branch for the origin remote.
I can inspect the local copies by
running git log origin/master.
Or git diff origin/master master.
But before I do that,
I want you to predict what you'll
see if you run these commands.
You can also run the commands
yourself to see if you're right, but
it can help to think about
this before trying it.
I'd like you to predict
the output of git log and
git status both before and
after you run git fetch.
If you run git log origin/master
before you run git fetch,
which of these commits do
you think will be shown?
Larry's commit, adding the chili recipe?
Your commit, adding a new spice?
Sarah's commit, removing cumin?
Check all that apply.
Similarly, check all the commits
you think will be shown after you
run git fetch.
When you run git status
on the master branch,
Git will let you know whether your local
master contains any commits that are not
reachable from origin/master or
vice versa.
If you run git status
before you run git fetch,
will it say that your local master is
one commit ahead of origin/master?
One commit behind origin/master?
Will it say that your
branch is up-to-date,
meaning the two branches
point to the same commit?
Or will it say the two
branches are out of sync,
meaning each has a commit
not present in the other?
Similarly, after you run git fetch,
what will git status say?